[Applaus]
[Musik]
er ist 17 jahre polizist
sie von kathi die
ausbildungsvermittlung dienen kannst du
wirklich unwohl ist wenn man diesen zwar
für ca
[Musik]
mendig kurz noch derzeit noch einmal
pädophile übergriffe de/shop die hälfte
mutmaßliche täter zu verhaften damit die
krebsmittel händler verschwinden oder
flüchtet
vor dem zugriff des briefing mit dem
kolleg von der kriminalpolizei
unterstützt
werden die konzerte analog wird in einer
sprache die
innovation objektivität und so bald noch
eine gant wurde freilich ein schnelles
bild vergangen
jetzt wenn sie zu versorgen
offenbar realität geworden wo in einem
auto mit laufendem motor setzt
bestätigt es ist nichts richtig
also mal hinter weil er zu hause in
treffen noch einmal wieder erreicht
[Musik]
kriminalpolizisten damit sie weiter
verdächtig grad mit nähe und mit der
hausdurchsuchung anfangen dies erkläre
werde man im auto ist mit dem gerät hat
wird noch mal da ist
ein bekannter von verdächtige erschien
jetzt mit dem fall
sie hat sie nie personalien
wieder zu fuß durch solche
einblicke wo der verdächtige sitzt
bewacht form ein polizist
vor zwei wochen wollte gleich alt sind
die mutmaßlichen opfer
integration in der persönlichen
rausgeholt zumal die ja gar nicht weiß
was alles passiert ist alex gilt noch
immer der schuld so mutig oder was man
das alles gelernt
[Musik]
der mutmaßliche täter lebte er hat nur
schlecht mit jugendliche 2
[Musik]
die ganz wenig wird akribisch durchsucht
diverse potenzielle bewies mitgeleitet
sichergestellt
fertige werk ist dann wohl mit dem vater
zu machen
damit ganz klar als die vorstellung
bisher war es auch für kunden und war
dort alles gut
und schön und ich habe bis zu strecken
überlegen speichermedium aber rob ist
denn frauen interessiert alles besonders
womit ich schlage die bilder oder videos
rennt finde
[Musik]
sogar ich gucke lieber hat der
speicherkarte versteckt
toni glück verwandlung
wäre peinlicher menschen
grüßen das wochentage brennend
eineinhalb stunden
später untersuchten spezialisten apps
wirklich irgendwo ii schlägt die bilder
oder videos hat
nach der hausdurchsuchung
polizisten mutmaßlich täter mit und
bringe den ist
passiert
im gefängnis
[Musik]
kriminalpolizei und staatsanwaltschaft
landschaft
die
personal und die personal begleitet
sie sind aufwendige selektionsverfahren
auf herz und nieren wurde und hans
schlussendlich geschafft
landschaft
brauchen nachwuchs
entsprechend schwierig
zu unterstützen
name ist am 24
von blauen und wollen jetzt im laufe
dieser ursprung des kraft machte profil
hat ein jahresgehalt geschafft noch
wenige
schließen
zieht militärische schafft bei den zug
wie die privatwirtschaft event
management von jetzt ein halb york
schafft und jetzt heute auto zum neue
werk staaten und zu meiner hobbys ich
mache kein sport velofahrer job und bin
ein guter musik und noch lange jahre
party in las gut vorstellen
ich habe fordert für gesundheit klärt
und ausschließen denn die plackerei denn
ich glaube vor zwei wochen abgeschlossen
euro in freetz
begleitet mich als sportler 18
ich bin boxen unterwegs um
wanderer
in alpiner klavier gut außer viel spaß
machen es gut und bizkit
ein serbe produzierte image wählen
sollte bevölkerung im blick geht ortet
vor der polizei aus landschaft und
potenzielle nachwuchs wie der beruf
interessieren viele bewerbe zwischen
aber nur wenige sind will schlecht
qualifiziert zum polizistin oder
polizist werden
drum hand viele chor nachwuchsproblem
natürlich andere firma wo interessante
tätigkeit wird dann sprechen sie mit
ihrer konkurrenzsituation märz um taylor
geschichte der medien war zeige dass der
beruf anspruchsvoll wenn es kalt und
treue polizeibeamte geht oder wenn es
große satz geht die polizei auch
kritisiert wird das zeigt dass nicht
immer einfach ist und dann geht so
objektiv wie grund wieso aus problem
geht wieder los war das heißt wer
sportlichkeit feilt und insbesondere im
beach viele junge gut qualifizierte und
schriftlich und das ist ein wichtiger
teil für unsere tätigkeit und das bringt
es mit sich dass manche die jungs war
einfach beschränkt ist
[Musik]
wie schneidet für den nachwuchs für
talente und klare lager
sowie historische moment ist dass die
unter die weste das sieht man das alles
schon trainer so würde man sehr unter
dem händler unter dem polo und rob lowe
einfach drunter aleks ristic zeigt klar
die politik kann quelle ich sie
respekt sicher aber ich denke wie sich
das ein effektives wirkstoff mieters
wird zeigen die ausbildung und was die
situationen das doch eine und wie man
muss reagieren und auf das vor allem
jetzt dass man das dass man das längere
wie das damit ihre unsicherheit oder der
respekt
angst
komme ich gedacht habe ich ein kreuzer
situation
habe ich jetzt geschafft hat
[Musik]
und am ehesten die persönliche
dienstwaffe nicht
was sie mit pistolen machen sie dürfen
sich zur notwehr verteidigen sie dürfen
brawn trage verwirrt nothilfe leisten
und zieht er versetzte zufällig vor
einer polizeilichen aufgaben waren
für manche droht alle bundes
vize kommandant erschwerend wirkte
bereits zu waffen übergeben
wirklich ihre persönliche dienste
dankeschön
das vize-kommandant ausspielen stille
bereits
verstehe ihre persönliche die 13
eine sitz kenntnis schoss militärdienst
anders sieht ist
immer ein guter grund respekt vorhanden
gegenüber der waffe oder damit sie
stehen besser gesagt wenn ich weiß für
was historische beweis für wasser
gesetzt war das
natürlich
ein mega partys kühl ich meinen teil
meiner wahnsinns verantworten es ist ein
gewisser stolz meinerseits haben die das
bureau
ev klima ist wie krimi satz war sehr
knapp dort trifft er muss immer vom
schlimmsten ausgehen dass nur selten ii
trifft
jetzt ehefrau hat alarm geschlagen sie
zwei tag kreis lebenszeichen von ihrem
nachbarn normalerweise sind täglich in
kontakt
der brief rauschte happening
klettern
jetzt
bleibt sie bewege vom stimmen
[Musik]
beschlossen und blutverschmiert in
boulder auch um eine der
schlüsselstellen
wir haben wir marine der hauptgang mit
dem schlüsseldienst oder beruf machen
und
die situation zu machen
und was
ist passiert
habt ihr
darüber
max ittigen und ich steh schaut wie
politisch wurde es
ist grundhaltung dass man ein bisschen
unterstützen
wenn
bürger dass sie ihre geschichte an
stimmen dass sie in den silos was ihnen
wichtig ist und es möglich der probier
dafür jetzt machen das was der fall gut
läuft
[Musik]
es ist zeit für eine verschnaufpause
der eshop wie und sind kolleg grillieren
dem garten vom polizeiposten
er hatte leer als
landmaschinenmechaniker gemacht und nach
der aeris neue idee kam polizist werden
belasten also vor allem die
unregelmäßige arbeitszeiten
früher mal 80 mittel denn mit der
schaltung
das belastet mich nicht einmal gegrüßt
ruit und
klinisch dementsprechend zum teil
verändert netz erlebte macht ihm
autokäufer es sind vor allem die
unregelmäßige arbeitszeiten sie's umfeld
belastet
[Musik]
einbruch gehabt
roche sind
nach links bringst du recht
das gut
wenn das erste batterie leer ist das
objekt und stelle was hat eckpunkt durch
61 dunkeln weil ich nicht wusste war
dass
sie das eine gemüse stecken ist aus dem
fenster und dann unter die hektisch
ganzen wirklich unwohl ist also immer
nur den 14 und nochmal in bereitschaft
denn bisher
hat sie nie waffen gezogen und
geschossen
drei spur verbrecher
luzerner seetal
deutschlandpolitik aus landschaft und
cedric konnten vor der zentral und
nordwestschweiz ihren nachwuchs
ausbildet 2060 stolzes kirch die
interkantonale polizeischule im
ehemaligen lehrerseminar hitzkirch und
offenland vom ehemaligen zivilschutz
ausbildungszentrum bach
über 250 r gehen die polizisten werden
jedes jahr ausbildet alle sechs minute
punkten neue lehrgang hits der beach
party bietet einander wirklich und diana
staehly
[Musik]
der free market kirche mit der aufgabe
motto persönlich an materialkosten
behinderten und warum russland claire t
alles ist neu nicht nur die vielen
anderen konnten
diana staehly versucht sich im überblick
verschaffen
dann ist wunder
grundausbildung gut zwei jahre ist er
stehe absolvieren
zweite jahr wendet das was glencore
praktischer und schlüsse das bildet mit
der eidgenössische berufsprofil ab
der anfang vom einen neuen
lebensabschnitt für diana staehly vom
gesundheitswesen zu der polizei
polizisten lösen emotionen muss auch
negative muss man dann keine unruhe dass
man nicht verliert ist aber so wie jetzt
das einhorn in köln stattfindet david
safier und darum als notwendige aktie
polizei
vergrößert oder die uniform zu reizfigur
für andere zu hoffnungsträgern
des stolzes bis zu 180 personen erhöht
oder er macht im oktober news billigen
hitzfeld ich begegne herzlich willkommen
die beamtinnen und beamte dort zu ihrem
ersten ausbildungstag
der nachwuchs sollte für sensibilisiert
werden dass rapid unter beobachtung
stand
zivilisten werdet polizisten ihr seid
vorbilder sie
und sie selig wesens mäßig
transformieren
der junge mann wurde elf machen seite
leiter von der grundausbildung
also wenn jetzt setzt rund läuft oder
unter den wänden möglichst schnell dass
es dann show oder den schärferen wolf
wird
der wolf ist eigentlich ist ihr wohl
hufe
eigenschaften mitbringt sowie eine
polizistin oder polizist der seit august
trifft auch und im rudel
dialog zu einem
sozialeren habe ich auch shakira ist
bedeutet das wenn wir das ist das lehrt
und sich entsprechend verhalten
diana staehly hat schon als kind quiz
dass sie zur polizei hat 24
ehrenamtliche sieht sind polizisten eine
davon ist jede geld
die inspiration dfb hat man hat mich
einfach überzeugt dass ich vor
polizistin war da und das
hat viel mehr hinter dem buch steckt als
nur ein eigentliches scheck zu unfällen
beim polizeiruf
und ja du machst das eigentlich im griff
das wort weiter
die grafik hat sie problemlos geschafft
vorfreude für ihre neue britische riesig
[Musik]
jedes opfer ohne zu wissen was eine über
etwas was für sich dort sehr ohne was
man vorlagen sehr viel aber mitnimmt und
das ist sicher ein faszination und holt
auch in extrem schwierigen situationen
für ihre zöpfe bauer die emotionen weil
sich das in schwierigen situationen
[Musik]
da wird richtig sozusagen genetisch
vorbelastet ritter polizei sind
partnerschaft bitte konkurs polizei
basel stadt im militär hatte sich als
führungspersönlichkeit profiliert und
bis zum kompaniekommandant braucht
jetzt machte sich fit für den
polizeidienst
also ich habe schon immer viel sport
gemacht aber ich zeige sich bei der
polizei mach ich definitiv mehr sport
kultur sport und
ja es ist einfach eine andere motivation
und dankeschön das gemacht weil ich weiß
was ich an mir und ich weiß dass mir und
wenn ihr denn in die nötige situation
dann entsprechend beraten
wie sie in kuba traum geht sich zum
einsatz
diana staehly übt fleißig unterstützt
wie die 22 jährige von ihrer mutter
wohl mein name ist ihre polizei
basel-landschaft sie eine anzeige machen
um es kurz zu und zwar im ich mich noch
bestem mussten aber drauf und ich möchte
mein auto damit autofahrer das zufällig
gesehen aber er steht das ab jetzt
bricht ihren namen und weniger drastisch
aus das wäre stierli andrea
hätte sie mir nachsagen floh vertrag
stelle oder nicht dh aus dem stroh
vortrag ich habe auch dass man eben
ermittler und dass sie den sack keine
entscheide obsthof klar also dass
dennoch bestraft fifa getan oder
zivilklage also das heißt dass sie ihr
schadensersatz bekommen oder genugtuung
für sich und arbeit ist aber das
passiert nur wenn sie der strafantrag
stellen damit das risiko
super danke
es ist eine respekt einfach
drauf achten spax verdammen was sie
macht
ich danke gesellschaft also die
aggression gegen die menschen in uniform
ist gewachsen finde ich und ich denke
sie macht
die aggressionen berger menschen in
uniform hat sich vor der krone virus
pandemie zum beispiel noch vors format
zeigt
besonders explosiv sind am mix begegnung
zwischen dem fc basel und zürcher clubs
ziehen
hochrisikospiel
[Musik]
de chapi ich regelmäßig zum sogenannte
ordnungsdienst steht wurde
1974 bildet sind am ein hochrisikospiel
entstanden dementsprechend ist es
richtig
also einen stonesoft stroms in
altersheimen genre von kalle runden
rennen lag und auch eine großereignis
mehrere personen politik festhalte
weitere abklärungen machen aber man
probiert natürlich möglichst wenig
verhaftet weil alles was man mitnehmen
sagt er und stimmt dann muss man auch
argumente und das braucht ressource aber
das soll nicht hinter aber mitnehmen
wenn straftaten begangen werden
ich spreche ich von einem satz
das ist der granatwerfer
munition verschießen 6 kombi ganz
anderes
ich bin der festen taxi schutz heißt
sich für der waffen mit nicole es hilft
schützen hat anna munitionsfabrik
polizei basel-landschaft unterstützt
beseitigen hochrisikospiel regelmäßig
ihre kollegen aus basel stadt
postiert sich nach dem stadion dann
heißt worte
das und sehr oft vor dass man lange
gewartet sieht der
ordnungsdienste zum rasieren präsidenten
zum vater
zurück in der polizeischule hitzkirch
irgendwann wird der diana stierli zum
ordnungsdienst dem fußballmatch vom fc
basel auf bomben und es kann zu
brenzligen situationen wo
selbstverteidigung wichtig wird
wenn er jetzt in die hand mit frage
bin ich gezwungen das nicht mit kraft
lösen sondern mit technik und techniker
schmerz 50 die umfragen sind klarer und
unternehmen keinen druck positionen
wir können wieder hindere bis an die
schäfer
unternehmen unternehmer ihr drucker
drucken
verordnen
zentrales wo und wie lange die techniker
angewandet werden
alles wurde polizist im boden ist sehr
sehr schlecht für ihn
dass leute sind hat vor dem kolleg
sofort widerruf einer reise in münchen
lösungen genau da trainieren jetzt kurz
am boden
und abrollen der stadtplan sozial
möglich das handbuch der bürger nicht
brauchen zumal abstützen
sechs mal ein bisschen bruderliebe
man kann ich das sagen hatten
im polizeikorps vladimir alles mit wort
löse man gewollt
vielleicht irgendwann auch
gesichter von
porta sicherheit
aber ich sehe auch nicht
real
polizeiberuf geschafft habe jemandem
schulisch erhalten das ist habe ich es
völlig anders
zurück im ordnungsdienst vordergrund
ihres pandemie der fußball macho ist
fertig es geht friedlich russ
dann plötzlich niebels zürcher fans
wählen ihre zugflotte mit der note
brennstoffe und randalieren
rheine
ex sponti minute am bahnhof trottel
ok
der zukunft zählt die vorteile wie und
verliert den kanton was landschaft jetzt
wird das problem von der aargauer und
später von den kirchen kollege
viera tx
[Musik]
krieg
auslösen magazin habe ich
glaube das neue magazin geholt wiederum
mit dem kriterium heim vom finger ich
setze die chips uwe kolks
der umgang mit dienstwaffe fängt mit
manipulations jährigen out loud und
entlade immer wieder
tankstelle du ständig wiederhole zum
automatismus lässt theorie dazu hat
johanna stähli schon verinnerlicht
über die notfall schieße wird ich danke
sicher aber wichtig ist dass ich vorher
sicher alle möglichkeiten geprüft hat
uns verhältnismäßigkeitsprinzip er wird
vom standard gots ist klassen sind
diese lust startet mit sehr viel macht
ist in rekrutiert worden also ich sind
die usa wo jetzt öffnet polizisten und
polizist werden 7 der sachverhalt
abklären also der sachverhalt erforschen
hat ernst stross für
wo gilt für bargeld sowie staates dienen
menschen ist so zeige wie wichtig ist
die grundbausteine bundes sie
ihnen wird viel theoretisches wissen
vermittelt
berufsethik tracht die psychologie
kriminalistik und vieles mehr
[Musik]
twitter gehört das zu den auftrag
siemens bietet mit dem gesetz mit dem
strafrecht vor allem oder und die
wechsel so sagen wenn er über
menschenrechte und prothetik retten
statt und falls mit dem thema macht und
verantwortung übernehme
wir sehen uns jetzt vorbereiten
ladendiebstahl wodurch stattgefunden
hätte und ich werde jetzt noch in der
kurve um in die situation den bearbeiten
und das machen sie zum ersten mal vor
immer noch die theoretische und jetzt
haben erhöht dass er schon mal eine
praktische fall der ladendetektiv und
filialleiterin sind vor ort und sind
momentan mit dem tag der anrede
praktische beginnen sie ihre
theoretische besser anfangen wandel
trainerwechsel atomics der pensionierte
landwirt als
polizisten
sie
den struktur beobachtet und macht man
diese
[Musik]
und sie sehen die noch heute schneidet
hauptstelle
ja
ja ja
ja das thema
wird
und
und wie sie sind jetzt in der situation
klarkommen die berechnung portemonnaie
bezahlen unternehmen die in rio sind
auch diesmal im rucksack geschnallt und
zurücksetzung star später zurückzahlen
das heißt sie haben das im rucksack und
sie denn richtig heiß gehandelter
15 außerdem
möchte sie so schnell ich kann dir zu
dem vorfall sagen
also patroulliert gewordene mit biete
ganz gut man ja vor allem im überblick
mehr konnte inneren blutungen war ich
war bis mäßig bis man weiß war jede
person ist und sich dann wenn er sein
merkt und nachher wir nicht mir den
kontakt wie verhalten sich die person
eigentlich mit dabei ich habe schon mit
libyscher kooperativ und er hat sich
schwierig
kontrolliert wurde die nicht durch
externe
und du hast mir die bremsen abgekauft
das erste interview
hätte gekonnt rechts verlässt das ist
doch eine
handy thematik und abnehmen du mehr
schmerzt mich die csu mehr und stärker
sorry doc garnicht
tasche sachverhaltsaufnahme us-dollar
haft und die 20 telefon
wir freunde ich denn da logisch da
passiert aber ablehne sehr dankbar femo
also grundsätzlich bin ich erzähler
performance ist jetzt halte
anfangsschwierigkeiten
sich einfach nicht so einfach alles
danke jetzt fehlt nur mit routine und
interessante schreibe mir hat mich statt
in jeder situation und ein basiertes
oder reagiert und den hund einmal sofort
diesen okay das hat nicht gepasst hat
das hatte ich eine besser machen am
schluss jetzt gutschein von hany azer
hopp mit verbesserungsvorschläge und
gedanken ist anders strand machen und
jetzt folgende sechs mal mit wenn es
denn wenn ihr denn die hatten wir die
möglichkeit das ganze denn weder orts
wander und seine zur besseren
[Musik]
manipulation sehr begrenzt
jetzt ist nur scharf geschossen
und je länger das die zierliche höhere
grundsteuer genau das gleiche diesen zug
besteht das sind die erste tricks und
dann ist noch länger
[Musik]
jonas ist okay auch das beste wetter
das schwäche von mir im moment sicher
gesetzt so unsere sache ja liebe macht
den meister
und sogar wenn
auch hoch stephanie auf patrouille
[Musik]
die einfach nicht provozieren also
katharine der 86 die sind ganz normale
ganz normale tür stand